helgoland die afg herzlicher bemüht die
wahlergebnisse von gestern als erfolg zu
bezeichnen sind sie wirklich zufrieden
mit dem was sie in bremen und bei der
europawahl eingefahren haben für die afd
ja wir sind mit beiden zufrieden
er wird zu recht gesagt es hätte auch
noch etwas mehr sein können aber in der
europawahl waren viele dinge gegen uns
erwähnt worden
strache bei exit kam es im britischen
unterhaus
das hat uns natürlich geschadet dazu kam
dass sie die abschaffung des
europaparlaments den wählern erklären
müssen
wenn ich diese gegenposition alle in
berechnung ziele dann muss ich sagen war
es ein sehr gutes ergebnis
jetzt haben sich auch in der
pressekonferenz bzw morgen darauf
hingewiesen welche erfolge die
befreundeten parteien in england in
frankreich in italien in polen und
ungarn hatten
das sind 20 bis 30 prozent in ungarn
polen sogar noch wesentlich mehr
dagegen wirkt das war allerdings der afg
aber wie das ergebnis von etwas
ärmlichen verwandten nein das kann man
nicht sagen wir alle wissen dass die
europäischen nationalstaaten völlig
unterschiedlich sind und dass die briten
eine protestwahl sozusagen veranstaltet
haben weil sie den tories eine auf den
kopf geben wollten das ist eine völlig
andere situation als in polen oder
ungarn das können sie mit deutschland
nicht vergleichen
die staaten sind halt doch so
verschieden dass sie nur die nationalen
besonderheiten in betracht ziehen können
und nicht jetzt vergleiche nicht nur
europa ist heterogen was wahlergebnisse
angeht auch deutschland in
ostdeutschland und westdeutschland gibt
es unterschiedliche wahlergebnisse in
zwei ländern in denen demnächst
landtagswahlen stattfinden brandenburg
und sachsen ist die afg stärkste partei
geworden
bekommt diese heterogenität man könnte
auch sagen spaltung deutschland gut
die bekommt deutschland natürlich nicht
gut aber ich kann sie nicht auflösen das
ist nun mal so
durch die historischen den historischen
weg der ostdeutschen bundesländer ist
das eine andere situation als in
westdeutschland ich habe darauf
hingewiesen die milieus gab es nicht das
betreute denken auf der anderen seite
wollen die leute in der ehemaligen ddr
nicht von daher ist diese situation die
können sie kaum beeinflussen die ist wie
sie ist
die klimapolitik spielte eine große
rolle bei dem im wahlkampf haben jetzt
gesagt das könnte möglicherweise ganz
anders werden wenn die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung sich in deutschland
verschlechtert hat so ein bisschen das
gefühl gehabt sie wünschen sich dass
regelrecht herbei ist will die afd daran
als krisengewinnler aufdrehen zu sagen
jetzt haben wir wirtschaftlich eine ganz
andere situation klimapolitik ist luxus
nein ich stelle nur fest dass diese art
von klimapolitik die die grünen
vertreten natürlich luxus ist das sind
wähler zum teil die ihre kinder mit dem
suff zum zur schule fahren in den urlaub
fliegen aber dann gutes gewissen also
ich mache indem sie die grünen wären und
das können sie sich so lange leisten so
lange wie hat es und jemand gesagt ja
pullover flauschig ist wenn es wieder
härter wird
können sie sich das nicht mehr leisten
und das
will ich gar nicht herbei reden aber es
wird so kommen und von daher habe ich da
überhaupt keine sorge dass der grüne
halb anhält
es gibt noch mal zurück zur europawahl
ja umfragen dass in letzter zeit
eigentlich die zuneigung zu europa zur
integration auch zu den europäischen
werten wieder stärker geworden ist
das ist ja auch etwas was zum beispiel
die cdu als europapartei immer
hochgehalten hat bedeutet das auch ein
bisschen wenn das europäische
bewusstsein in deutschland wieder
stärker wird dass er die möglichkeiten
für die afg begrenzt sind gerade wähler
aus dem bürgerlichen konservativen lager
dafür zu wird oder davon zu überzeugen
dass man zur afg über laufen sollte das
kommt ganz darauf an wie sich die
europäische union entwickelt wenn sie
sich so weiterentwickelt wie das im
moment aussieht das heißt immer mehr
zentralisierung glaube ich nicht dass
unsere position schwächer wird
wenn es reformen gibt haben wir ja auch
gesagt wir wollen eine zurückführung auf
den gemeinsamen markt wenn es also
vernünftige reformen gibt dann könnte so
etwas auch uns nutzen das kann man heute
nicht voraussagen
soweit alexander gauland im phoenix
interview danke schön dass ihr da nur